Not to this part of it, but to that, yeah,
I'm rubber Coolidge and I'm Latif Nasser. Thank you. And, uh,
today on radio lab, I, Robert,
I am going to make you wrestle with your most cherished ideal American
democracy. Oh, I see. Okay, great. Uh, wait, hang on a second.
I'm just struggling of the offense now. I have one. Okay. Okay, great. And,
and I'm going to start things off by introducing you to Yasha.
Yasha Munk. I'm a lecturer on government at Harvard. He studies politics, uh,
Duh, Duh, Duh, Duh Duh, Duh. What I suppose I was going to say, uh,
maybe we could just start with where you grew up. Yeah, so I was, um, so I,
I was born 1982. I uh, grew up in Germany, moved,
moved around a bunch of different places for Germany as a kid and then went to
college in England, Cambridge in 2000.
And I was kind of studying politics. I was a history major.
So Yasha was studying politics, but he was studying it in the past.
So he was looking at, you know,
going all the way back to the cradle of democracy in ancient Greece and then how
democracy came to thrive around the world. But as he was studying that,
he was noticing, you know, in the news,
he would see in certain countries like France or Austria, you know,
there would be these parties,
these far right ultra nationalist anti-immigrant parties that were starting to
gain some traction. And for Yasha, I saw some of this,
this was a little bit scary because my family's been in the wrong place at the
wrong time for about four generations.
His great grandparents perished during the Holocaust.
My grandparents sort of barely survived.
Ms. Howard Jr and my hands grew up in Poland and were thrown out of the country
and a huge sort of antisemitic wave in 1968. And so the idea that, you know,
political system that seemed relatively stable, it's emergency, peaceful,
might sudden uterine fractures and, and even violent. Um,
something that I suppose I,
I always had to sort of dim awareness of even as a kid.
So I remember being quite worried by this and having friends who were quite
worried about it,
but we were worried about it as sort of this weird bad thing that's going on.
I didn't think we actually fought that these people might win jump to early 2010
did he start winning for the first time?
Molly Napan will have a seat in parliament along the seven others from her far
right party
these far right parties in Austria and France.
They start to gain power and it's not just there that huge swaths of Europe.
What?
What's what's happening in the Israeli is also happening elsewhere in Europe.
Similar rate when Cardi start rising up and it'll leave Greece, the Netherlands,
Poland, Hungary,
an identity crisis for the entire European continent and it's not just Europe.
You have India, Turkey and
what started off as of course United States. Unlikely.
Impossible is now reality. Basically
there's this wave of politicians whose message was people aren't really
listening to you. Your government has failed you. Trust me,
I would speak for the people I'm going to fix.
And to Yasha this was, you know,
this was like a wake up call and not just because of immigration policy or right
and left leanings of certain politicians, but even more deeply than that.
I was quite worried about the way in which these political movements perhaps
pretended to have some allegiance to democratic mechanisms.
But actually when you were enemies of it,
like there was this one guy, the leader of the Austrian Freedom Party
glorified the third,
right in various ways and really harking back to the country's fascist past in a
positive way. Uh, that wasn't a farfetched fear, I don't think.
I mean,
a huge number of the world's dictators have been elected democratically at some
point,
and then they move against democratic institutions in such a way that you con
displays from democratically anymore.
So for Yasha, who by this point was a lecturer at Harvard, he, you know,
kept seeing this in country after country after country.
He saw these citizens willingly elect these wannabe dictators into power.
And so he started wondering what is making the citizens do this?
Do they, do they feel like their current leaders don't get them? Do they,
are they, are they riled up about, you know, some issue of the day, like,
like refugees or income inequality? Or is this
sign that they're upset about something even more foundational?
The political system itself,
like are they actually angry with democracy itself?
And so I sat down with a friend and colleague, um, to figure it out.
And his friend, it turns out,
worked on something called the world values survey,
which is a video ambitious attempt to try and get a public opinion around the
world.
It's basically just a bunch of social scientists who ask a whole bunch of very
standard questions to a whole bunch of people all over the world.
And they're like, okay, well let's, let's actually like scrutinize what,
what's being said in here about democracy.
And when we actually looked at the numbers
this [inaudible],
uh, we would, you know, honestly flabbergasted by what we saw. Oh,
okay.
So there's actually three questions in particular that he got interested in.
Okay. Here. So let's start with, uh, this one.
How do you feel about a strong ruler who doesn't have to bother with parliament
or elections who doesn't have to bother with parliaments or elections? Correct.
Yeah. Okay.
And they also ask this of Americans just instead of doesn't have to bother with
parliament. It was, doesn't have to bother with Congress anyway.
So in 1995 24% of all Americans endorsed that kind of strong man leader.
24 so you know, one out of every four. Yeah.
But in the last several years,
that number has jumped from 24 to 32% so now it's a third almost.
That's a, yeah.
Say a strong leader who doesn't have to deal with Congress or elections is
either very good or fairly
good thing. Wow. Wow. That surprises me. It's kind of,
it's kind of even more striking in Europe. So in, in Germany,
one in six people used to life but idea,
but now to one in three in Germany where they should know better.
Yeah. In France and United Kingdom,
it was one in four 20 years ago and now it's one in two half, half. Yeah.
So every second rit and Frenchman says, yeah,
the idea of a strong ruler who doesn't have to bubble of parliament
introductions, that's pretty appealing to me. It's not appealing to me.
That is not appealing to me.
Who would say that they like to not be involved in a democracy,
which is about being involved. Ah, okay. Well if you think that's crazy.
Here comes question number two, uh, flat out simple, straight forward.
How important is it to, to live in a democracy on a scale of one to 10.
And when you look at Americans born of the 1930s and 1940s,
two thirds of them give the highest importance to living in a democracy.
I say that's really essential. Well, two third seems a little soft to me. Sure.
But among Americans points since 1980, it's less than one third,
less than one third. Consider it essential to live in a democracy.
What? Less than a third? Yeah.
So over a hundred people, a hundred young people, 30 to 30, 30,
25 would say, I love democracy. That's very important than the rest.
What would the rest say? It's not, it's not the most important thing for them.
Deciding where to live. Okay. When, if, if you are, if this is good,
where would you like to, like what would you prefer?
Would you like to be living? That's a good segue to the next question.
A final question, which was about army rule.
So do you think for the army rule is a good system of government army rule?
So we're not, this is no civilians anymore.
Soldiers running the government soldiers following orders,
soldiers giving orders. So 20 years ago, um,
about one in 16 Americans fought that was a good system of government.
Uh, and the most recent poll a couple of years ago,
it was one and six and among young and affluent Americans,
it's actually gone up from 6% to 35%.
So it's a six fold increase in America.
You have one in three young affluent Americans.
I am military rose a wonderful thing. That's what you're saying. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. That's misguided or tragic.
I don't know which. So Yasha said something, he was like, look like,
I don't think of a colonel's took over tomorrow. Uh,
one third of Americans would say, this is wonderful. I,
I don't think that's actually true,
but it does show a deep lack of attachment to the current political system and
this sort of sense of, you know what I mean? Let's try something new.
How bad could things get? I didn't think it could be much worse than what
we have today. Here's, here's the thing that gets to be,
let's imagine a well intentioned but totally authoritarian dictator who takes
over, gets used to power,
and then as dictators do chooses to remain in place forever.
The adventure of democracy is that it admits that nothing is ever right.
We always have to fix it and the system has built in it.
Even permanents every six years you elect a senator over again every two years
you elect the congressman over again.
Every four years you can have the option to switch presidents.
Presidents can't serve beyond a particular point. There will be checks,
there will be balances, they will be protection.
But the whole thing admits that there's always change and always the ability to
change. And this trip that you just read me, he says, Nah,
we don't believe in it anymore. Well that's dangerous to me. Scary to me.
I think my response is if that's the case and I don't argue that people have
these opinions, if that's the case, then let's fix it. Let's not throw it out.
Let's repair it in some way.
That's w that's what it seems like a moment like this calls for.
That's the speech basically.
You're saying let's fix it. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, um, I mean, and there's,
there's a lot to fix, right? Obviously there's,
there's corporate money and special interests,
lobbyists and gerrymandering and minority groups who don't get a voice and
active voter suppression in a lot of places.
The weirdness of the electoral college to two party system in general where it
seems like they have nothing to do except for hate on each other. Um,
but the thing is so, so just focusing like take this very specific week,
this week that we are talking about this, there is a midterm election coming up.
And so I figured, let's like, let's just focus on one thing, voting.
Like,
is there a way to just tweak this fundamental part of democracy?
Like can we change the way we vote so that people don't feel as many people now
do that they're throwing their vote away, that their vote doesn't count,
that their vote, uh, um,
it's a wasted. Okay.
So what would you suggest?
So what I got is a kind of an alternate universe. It's, it's,
it's a different way of doing elections that could have a profound effect on the
way our democracy works. Ab, can you hear me? Yes, there we are. Oh good.
Okay, cool. And we're going to start off with producer Simon Adler. Yeah.
So in search of democratic inspiration,
I called across the ocean to the Emerald Aisle to talk to this guy.
So my name is Ab Philbin Bowman.
I currently work for Archie Radio One on the drivetime program abs,
a radio producer reporter for Ireland's equivalent to the known as art
t e and he's a self-described election nerd. Okay.
So just sort of start from the start please.
The way I would look at this as American democracy is one of the oldest
democracies in the world.
It's kind of like a laptop from 1985 and at the time everybody was like,
oh my God, this is incredible. It's so fast. It's so responsive.
You're going to get so much stuff done with this, and to be fair, you did,
but you've got to keep updating your operating system.
Otherwise pretty soon your democracy is struggling to deal with things like
Facebook news feeds and Twitter and leave yourself open to being hacked by
Russia. Now in Ireland, we got our democracy a little bit later,
the 1920s okay.
And at that point democracy had moved on from the 1770 1780s when you guys sort
of brought in your democracy and we adopted this, what was then quite modern,
uh, voting system, Cooke PR.
S. T. V. R. S. T. V. Exactly. It sounds a bit like an STD.
It does sound quite like a sexually transmitted infection. It does, yes. Oh,
this seems like dead in the water from hello.
The extended version is multi-season PRS TV. That's really sounds like an STI.
It's not one more time. Say it again. Multiset p.
R. S. T, V,
which stands for multi-season proportional representation by single transferable
vote. I have no idea what that means. Well,
weird as it might sound. This is a system of voting that unlike ours,
I can make every voter feel hurt. Oh,
gets you candidates who best reflect the collective interest of the people and
and make sure no one ever feels like they're throwing their vote away.
I don't believe you. You don't have,
you don't have to believe all I'm following. Tell us,
tell us how this impossible feat w how does this even work?
I'm walking through the lower part of Dublin central. Well,
let's just put this in concrete terms. Great. Okay,
so 2016 there's an election for the national parliament in the Dublin central
district.
It's blocks of brick rowhouses punctuated by these brightly colored pink or
purple or yellow doors.
You can think of it like an election district in Ireland.
It's what's known as a constituency, couple adult stores, low rise,
white public housing units.
It's predominantly working class constituency with lots of difficulties.
This is Moreno Sullivan,
a longtime resident of the constituency with the shock of white hair.
And I've always been involved with youth clubs, et Cetera,
doing volunteer work and then teaching in communities in the area.
And so back in February of 2016 this area of Dublin,
along with the rest of the country,
w was holding their parliamentary elections elections for what they called t ds.
Wait, what are tds? Okay, but TJ is the Irish, the gray.
Look for chuck to do all that,
which translates into a member of parliament at that time. Dublin central head,
three of these TD seats, three people representing them in parliament.
One of them [inaudible] I was elected in 2009 was Maureen and I would be,
I am independent, not allied with any party.
And going into that 2016 election,
things were looking pretty uncertain for marine. Uh, first of all,
there was a field of 15 candidates running for those three seats in worse seats.
One and two, uh,
were expected to be snagged quite easily by these two high profile major party
candidates. This again is ab Bowman who actually covered this 2016 election.
They're, they're not locked down,
but these are people who look like they are going to get elected.
And what that means is you've got this wide open field of folks all fighting
against marine for that third and final seat who is our contenders will, right.
So we're gonna focus in on two of them.
Can I just get you to introduce yourself? So I'm Mary Fitzpatrick first.
We've got married Fitzpatrick on the spectrum of American politics.
Do you know where you fall? You just have two Parsons,
she's pretty liberal. Been around Irish politics for awhile.
And you went through Naomi already. Okay. Or on second. Gary Gannon,
who's a young community worker, this brash guy with red stubble on his face.
Quite interesting quote, authentic.
And he's sort of an interesting one to watch because he's representing this
brand new political party, a plucky upstart.
I think that's what they call it in the West Wing. And uh,
did you have a slogan or anything like, Oh yes. No. What an amazing slogan.
It was very simple and it was just the one word.
If,
oh, I started completely from an old fable about when the Macedonian army was
marching on Sparta and they send spire to a message saying that if we,
when we were born Sparta to the ground,
we will enslave your women and kill your children.
Inspired to send back room more message, you're saying?
Yes, yes.
Like I said, Brash.
And then you've got other voices who are left wing or environmentalist or, or,
or others. So that's our field. All right.
And now here's how things actually work.
Over in Ireland I was saying is underway in the Republic of Ireland as the
country elects 157 new members of its parliament.
So Day of the election comes as a, as an Irish citizen,
you walk into the voting booth and it's a very,
very long ballot because it has all of the candidates, all 15 of them,
their photo, their name, and then align next to them.
And this ballot is a key component of that updated Irish laptop of democracy.
Uh, because instead of just filling in the circle next to one of those 15,
you say, my number one choice is this guy. My number two choice is this lady.
My number three choices, this person.
And you can go all the way down the [inaudible] giving preferences to as many
different people as you like.
You write in a number next to each candidate. How about one man, one vote.
Got It. Well, uh, it's still one man, one vote. We can't be no, it is. It is.
It is. It is. And at the end of the day,
your vote will only have counted for one person. However, in the voting process,
you're not just measuring what everyone's first choice.
It's like you might have a favorite choice,
but you're not totally equal about the other three choices.
And what this system allows us to do is to reflect that.
It allows you to say how you feel about the rest of the candidates.
And if your first choice doesn't make it,
if he or she is way down the list and out of the running,
then your vote lives on in the form of your second choice.
So for as long as there's a viable candidate with your number on it,
your vote will stay alive in the system. Is,
is this too early for me to raise a f a warning flag? Or you can wave.
I may ignore it, but let's see it or hear it. The,
the commitment that people make to voting is slight.
Most of us are into lunch, sports work,
and then maybe on the day of a vote, they have their best friends.
So you got to vote for Sally. Like they no one, they,
they're not even gonna know. Seven. Yeah.
So the first smell of this is it would take us more time than we want and we
might walk away from this exercise because we don't feel prepared.
You can engage with this on whatever level you'd like. Robert,
if you only know one candidate's name,
you can just put your one next to that person and hand in your ballot.
And you're done. Or let's say there's a candidate on there you really,
really don't like, you can leave them off the Polish entirely.
You're ranking your preferences. It's very simple, fairly good answer.
Okay, so let me walk you through how this plays out.
So polls closed at 10:00 PM on Friday,
February 26th and then
Dan all hell broke general election,
2016 on RTE radio,
one with Rachel English and Sean are real action begins.
It's going to be a dre of drama, shocks and surprises.
So what happens is we vote on the Friday and on Saturday morning the votes
actually get counted for Dublin Central.
Dublin central gets counted in one central location, which is the rds.
Let's go first to Ireland's largest count center, the rds,
the Royal Dublin society. Sean, thank you very much.
Welcome indeed to the rds where we're barn like building with big vaulted
feeling big, big hole, huge amount of noise.
[inaudible]
we'll let them realize they're going to go to them post traumatic trauma of the
whole thing of going to black than now. No, I'm joking. I actually was lovely.
The doors open at nine o'clock and I arrived this big throng arriving.
This is male male, Mark Cuban.
He's a campaign worker for our endangered incumbent, Maureen Moreno Sullivan.
And on the morning of the count,
as he pushed his way through these heavy wooden doors,
what he would've seen was this cavernous hall filled with people milling about.
Everybody's got clipboards. There's people with tons of sandwiches,
made tea and coffee in abundance and everybody's really excited.
And so shortly after nine o'clock,
all the boxes come in these giant metal boxes of ballots [inaudible] so the
boxes are opened. Literally,
they're lifted up and there is a cascade and the spilling of all this paper
because it's all done by paper. Voting weight.
What? Yeah,
we try to electronic voting in this country and we didn't like it because it was
very fast.
And I think we realized that the drama of an election and and also the,
the ritual of democracy gets everybody engaged and gets people watching.
It's like watching a sport, a big sports game.
You don't want it to be over in five minutes. They're off.
And so time now for our live update,
I have to warn as we always do at this time on this day,
we're talking tallies first of all,
which obviously can skew the results not just at the rds and not just for Dublin
Central,
but all across the country vote cancers or dumping boxes of votes and going
through them and putting them into stacks. First in Kilkenny is Justin McCarthy.
Rougher bundles in no particular order,
75% of the boxes have been tallied here and they include early on here at the
counter. They're just trying to get a handle on how many first choice votes each
candidate is getting from Calvin Audrey Carver,
100% of the boxes are open and and well the ballot counters are doing this and
official count. There's another group of people standing next to them,
the Atlantic way and Johnny guys doing their own unofficial calculations. Yes,
definitely the tallyman. 88% of boxes opened on tallied court. North Central.
All doctors open, all sheets tallied, tally tallyman.
There are several of them put forward by each candidate and they're just looking
over the railings waiting for you to torn that ballot.
Brash up started Gary Gannon again today can share though the name of the
prison. They got the number one preference healing Gannon,
number one Gannon gallery,
and they're just counting them up and what they're counting is that number one?
Yes. They're shouting out and telling the first choice labeled on each ballot so
you'll have it understand why they got the racist,
which [inaudible]
seemed like Gary, what?
We have a 98% Holly and there is a growing belief here that the third seat will
be between Gary Gannon and he was getting a lot of birth preferences,
so I walked in, I got pulled over,
but one of our national newspapers to do an interview.
Let's bring Gary Gannon in. How you, Gary,
it's too early to be saying you're over the line butcher.
You're going well and God is far too early.
I think all the radio researchers are coming over, grabbing me,
bringing me over to speak on the radio. There's a bunch of,
you've done 9% as well, so we could be in for another dog fight there.
Absolutely. Yeah. I've counseled my weekend plans. I think I'll be,
I think I'll be here for a awhile. It was genuine, real noise,
sense of excitement,
but not for everyone.
So that morning I was at home doing different things. Again,
this is incumbent Moreno Sullivan, but what did you do? Did you make breakfast?
Did you go for a walk? Did I had,
I had my breakfast and I walked the dog and um,
white fluffy dog and his name is Bailey.
So I brought him for a walk or you listening to the radio?
You're totally disconnected. Yeah, pretty much.
I let my campaigners go over to be part of the Itali campaigners.
It's starting to kind of including Mel. So
within, within the first hour from some of the tallies that we were seeing,
um,
[inaudible]
you know what I mean? Like Maria isn't, isn't picking up I no floats.
I'm saying, Oh,
I hope this is not going to be an early day where there's no need for you to
hang around because nobody's in the race any longer.
Um, and then I think I was driving when I got the first call from, um,
my campaigners over in the, the count saying it's not looking good.
Beautiful was elected.
Let's go back now to the busiest count center of the mall to Mary Wilson and the
RTS. Rachel, thank you very much. A first count imminent,
we believe here in Dublin Central. Meanwhile,
the counter is take all those ballots now officially sorted by first preference
and they pick up the stack for each candidate on the table and walk that stack
back to this wooden shelving unit again.
Mary-Faith Patrick behind the tables. I had a little bit of a distance in the,
in the center,
this giant third of Cubby pigeonholed just like light flimsy wooden boxes.
And this is the sacred shrine of Irish democracy on this day.
The cabi absolutely. Because,
because when they've counted all of the first preference votes,
they placed them all in their respective cubbies.
There's a hush in that part of out the arena and the returning officer stands up
on a stage with a microphone and goes following is the result of one here is the
first count for the constituency of Dublin central 68, 66.
And they read out every candidate how many number one votes did they get?
21 to zero. And uh, first off the bat
at the end of the first count,
first and second are pretty much locked down with the two people everybody
expected to with. But, but, but,
but then in third place unexpectedly is Mary Fitzpatrick. Yeah. I,
I mean I was very pleased to be in third position on the first count.
Now with our system of voting at this point, you're done. The,
the election is over. Uh,
the two front runner candidates would have each one a seat and then Mary
Fitzpatrick would have went to see Gary and Maureen. They'd be out done.
But in Ireland, not so in Ireland, they're just getting started.
So back to the race. And remember at this moment,
Mary Fitzpatrick is in third, Gary is in fifth,
and in seventh at that stage I was listening to the radio and I knew what they
were saying about Dublin central is incumbent, Moreno Sullivan. Okay. Um,
represented,
appears almost certain that Joe Costello and Moreno Sullivan are set to lose
that myself and Joe Castello, you're out. I had some y,
y because of the numbers.
I think the feeling was I was too far down that first preference to come back
up. But then looking at the earlier,
the results coming in from around the country. Like I said, it's not over yet.
So the way the votes progress is this,
the sheriff or the presiding officers starts to eliminate candidates.
The first elimination is the bottom three candidates.
Those candidacies are gone and in the bin since Gary's in fifth and marines in
seventh, they're safe for now. But the bottom three candidates, they're gone.
Why three?
Because they are so far out that mathematically they could never come back.
Between the three of them, they've only got like 150 votes.
So we get rid of all three of them and redistribute those ballots.
So if you voted for those people, they just go, okay,
who did you vote for as your second choice?
And the point is your vote is still live and is still part of this election.
And so that was 150 votes. Those hundred and 50 ballots,
they begin to do this sort of ballet, the roll in these pigeonholes,
everything is visible.
The vote counters walk back to that shrine to that cubby and pull the balance
from the cubby holes for those three candidates.
Then march these ballots back to to the front table,
sort them then into bundles of second preference on the ballot.
So now you've got stacks for every candidate that was listed as a second choice
and we distribute them,
they take them back to the cubby where they are then added to the remaining
candidates first preferences, and that becomes the second count.
Okay. Okay.
So what they want is everybody who voted to the degree that it is possible
should maybe be participating in electing somebody to the legislature. Exactly.
All right. So excuse me. What time is it now? Ah,
we're probably middle of the afternoon at this point. And when did we start?
We started at nine in the morning. Okay. Point taken. People are tired.
No, no, no. Blaming people. I am now watching this program for five hours.
That's a long time.
I will challenge your statement that just because a competition unfolds slowly
that it is without drama or suspense. All right.
I'm sorry that we were making this so hard for you. That's fine.
You are not making it easy for us. Anyway, back to the scene.
Dublin central is reduced to three seats, so I'm looking at this going, okay.
Mary Fitzpatrick, our candidate in third after the first count has 2,500 votes.
Gary Gannon currently in fifth. He's only 200 votes behind her,
and my instinct is he's going to be more transfer friendly.
He's going to get more second choice votes than her.
I think he could overtake her and I start watching her where the transfers are
going and I start to be proven right.
If the Social Democrats did very well on transfers to Kent, to Gary.
Gannon is getting 20 votes and then if it's Patrick's only getting to,
can't treat the whole process repeats, knock somebody out, do the ballot ballet,
redistribute those transfers. Gary Gannon picks up 60 votes and money
if it's Patrick only picks up seven so he's gaining on it already there talking
about me. You're asking who is this going, where is he coming from?
All these things. And then I was getting a phone call. Mary's stock is falling.
Well Gary's Mary, Mary's stock is staying static. You know,
we were struggling for transfers. That was the issue.
She's not going up much and the others are gaining on her. So yeah,
it's painful. It's not pleasant.
And bear in mind that you've still got other people picking up boats there.
We're seeing little pickups from Maureen. Maureen picked up 49 push. No,
not a lot. We're moving ahead slowly. Okay.
We have a a Dublin center count count four again,
eliminate the bottom candidate, redistribute those votes this time around.
Really not much changes. Then count five, the next person going out.
It's got 800 votes, 31 of them go to Mary Fitzpatrick,
but also 190 of them go to go to Gary Gannon, Gary Gannon.
I surprised a lot of people in disability to pick up transfers from and Gary
Gannon has just jumped into fourth place.
We've got quite a fight now in our hands. Be standings as they are,
so at the places aren't married. Patrick in third place,
she's just barely holding on in forth hot on her heels is Gary Gannon and then
way at the back of the pack still in seventh is incumbent Moreno Sullivan.
That's the state of play at ten five [inaudible] number six Oh, here we go.
And continuing coverage. Mike, Mike and Gallaher don't these here guys. Hello,
we're back. This is where two two big things happen.
Everybody's having their own conversations, obviously.
One Mary Lou McDonald of Champagne and Mary Lou McDonald of Shin Fein.
One of the front runners expected to take a seat, gets over the line.
[inaudible]
also come walking around and just hug them people.
Gary Gannon now jumps into third place.
It was invigorating pushing Mary Fitzpatrick out of a winning spot like that.
It was on the transfers like got cost and that's it. Cheap never recaptured it.
So the woman who under our system would have one off the bat.
She lost out his age, you know,
still hanging on in second to last but but also disheartened is our incumbent
Moreno Sullivan who's expecting to lose and I suppose maybe seven o'clock people
started to arrive.
She actually invited her campaign staff and volunteers back to her place for a a
concession party and I said, when people came in,
I don't want to know anything about the elections. I'll catch up tomorrow.
Unknown to me because I was busy with the tea and the the drinks and the foods.
Some of them in the house were still in contact with those over in the rds
[inaudible] central constituency into our reporter Damien O'Mara. Damien,
you have a development to report one of those guys still over in the rds was
Mel. I did have a sense looking at the numbers and saying, well,
okay Bush if, and then maybe
has the chance this a chance in this,
is that a crazy thought to have or a very smart thought to? Um,
it was just a thought to have because despite the fact that all day the media
had been saying that Maureen was out,
Moreno Sullivan had to lose going to the Moreno Sarina Sullivan might be
eliminated seven, something starts to happen.
[inaudible] coming around the band,
Gary Gannon looks like he's in poor position,
but all of a sudden we weren't reallocating people's.
Second preferences are the, toward preferences.
We'd got to the stage where we're reallocating people's fourth, fifth,
and sixth preferences. Because keep in mind,
most people's votes are still flushing around the system. And at this point,
not only has their top choice been knocked out,
but they're second and third as well.
So their vote is now being kept for their fourth, fifth, or sixth place choice.
And a lot of those, they start going to Maureen.
She's known people for years had been elected twice previous to that.
So even people who weren't involved from number one, number two number tree,
their votes were still cardio on past the Fars and the [inaudible] and just
mauled me on those transfers. So we go to candidate, the beginning to make it,
but I've gotten into this straight marine makes this massive jump vaulting her
ahead of two opponents into fourth place. Now,
just a couple hundred votes behind. Gary, do you have any sense this? No, no,
no,
because I didn't have the television on and they decided not to tell me not to
raise my hope from the ninth counter. At the moment, the ninth count,
the situation is that another candidate is asked, they redistribute her votes.
It's coming down, it's coming down to it. I'm going to count up those transfers.
That means then that Gary Gannon is lucky to be elected or what's the situation
there? Mikey dollar. Maureen get some 300 more transfers than Gary,
meaning suddenly Gary Kaolin is precisely eight votes ahead of Marlene. Who?
Sullivan. Oh my God. I did not see that coming. She's within eight votes of him.
I run quarter to 10,
but Maureen meanwhile is still convinced she's going to lose.
She's actually heading down to the count center to concede the race.
I said to myself, I should go over and concede. So um,
came out into the car and as I'm driving over to concede,
I was just at the traffic lights.
I can picture it and at that stage the phone call comes,
she looks at her phone and it's one of her campaign staff calls. I thought,
why are they ringing me to hurry me up to get over or whatever.
But in fact they were calling because in Dublin central, but Brian Darling,
you been just as I mentioned your name Brian, we're going to Dublin
essentially. What last time up?
This is the results of the 11th count for Dublin Central
and I deemed the following candidate to be elected and they are
Marino, Sullivan
[inaudible]
in her car. Maureen did eventually pick up and then it was, where are you?
You're about to be elected, going to be elected.
She put down the phone, drove to the count center
and when she arrived,
crazy applause. Great homes, great kisses. So,
and it was just a lovely explosion of feeling warm feelings towards me from
everybody. Moreno Sullivan. Congratulations. Thank you very much.
You're a very relieved woman. I'm a stoned woman. I was at home,
reconciled to a new life outside of politics and then suddenly I'm back in the
frame. We had thought that we were too far behind too. So I just said, look,
I know who as Lazarus felt like
[inaudible]
it was, it was that kind of moment.
Well, should we,
is this a story of a multi [inaudible] proportional representation by single
transferable vote working? How exactly is it?
It's meant to or is this sort of a perversion of the system?
No, it absolutely is.
It work that they worked at exactly as single transferrable votes with men to
do.
One last time, the gracious Gary Gannon,
everybody got their cow. Everybody got their say and everybody got their vote.
And don't get me wrong when I say like it did Hort, but I mean,
I was 28 29 then like there was a huge sense of like,
we'll show you this language will be back. So single transferable vote on that.
They worked against me. But you know, I think it worked out perfectly,
perfectly. I mean, let me just share if I get this right,
there's this woman Maureen,
who hardly anybody loves,
she's scores almost no votes as, as the favorite.
She's just everybody's, you know, [inaudible] fourth, fifth, sixth. I'll choose
Maureen Penn yet because the votes to keep getting shuffled and shovels and
shoveled, it's mismatch. Who becomes the winner? Winner? She's,
she's chosen because a lot of people don't hate her.
Yeah. Well, so, ah, so he,
here's what it makes me think of. Right?
And I had this moment where I was just imagining if we had been using this at
various crucial moments in our very recent history,
things could have gone an entirely different way.
Take the American presidential election of 2016 okay.
Between Hillary and Donald Trump, Hillary Clinton,
but also Gary Johnson and Jill Stein. Right? He voted for them.
Well, no, but hardly, hardly anybody. That number of hardly anybody is,
that was,
that's a sizable enough number that they could have swung the election one way
or the other. If you look at really key states, the deciding states, uh,
if you presume Gary Johnson's votes were split,
and if you presume all of Jill Stein's votes went to Hillary Clinton,
Hillary Clinton would have won Pennsylvania,
Michigan and Wisconsin and the whole kit
kaboodle. Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah. The weird thing is you can just keep playing this game and,
and it'll drive you crazy, but you can keep playing.
So if you go back to the 2016 Republican primary is where Donald Trump emerged
victorious, right? Over 10 people or something like that. Over 10 people. Right?
But there was a sizable number of people in those primaries who were never
Trumpers.
If those people hadn't been able to block their votes together,
they might've been able to, uh,
rally behind a candidate who was not Donald Trump.
And then rewind even further back to the 2000 election where the number of votes
that Ralph Nader got in Florida were more than the difference between Bush Scott
and Gorgon. No, elected elect the Republican. Can you, okay, so, so,
so go back to Ross Perot, right?
A George h w Bush was running against Bill Clinton in 1992, uh,
Ross Perot.
It's very controversial whether he really was a spoiler in that election,
but I mean if you ask the the Bush people, they say he definitely was.
And so if the parolers went to Bush that then like Bill Clinton would've just
been a historical footnote. He wouldn't have been the president. Like,
it's like a huge, huge seismic difference
in world history.
So when we come back,
we're not going to be looking at my own imaginative math.
We're going to look at what is ranked choice actually look like if there was in
the United States, because it is in the United States. That's about to happen.
Yeah. Let me come back.
Hi, my name is Corey and I'm from Minneapolis, Minnesota.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
welcome back. I am Robert Krulwich.
I'm lot's of Nasr and this is radio lab and we are trying to fix democracy in
this hour in little bits and pieces. Yeah. So let me,
let me just back up for a second because we have been talking about this and
thinking about this around the office for for a little while and at some point
as we were, as we were kind of meditating on this dwindling faith in democracy,
one of our fellow producers at our sister show more. Perfect. Okay.
Sakari she just took me and Simon. Great, great.
And just dragged us into a studio.
Okay. So um,
we've been having this conversation about whether our democracy is broken for
like a few months now. And like every meeting that we've had,
I've been the one in the room being like, guys are democracies fine?
Like have you seen other places, this is crazy. Like,
who are these people that think like our democracy is broken?
Like they don't know what they're talking about.
And do you know why? Like where, where, where's that feeling coming from?
Well, uh, okay. Can you tell me your name? Uh,
[inaudible] and who are you? Probably because of this woman. Oh, I'm was,
I was ma how you in relation to me? Oh, I'm your mom.
My mom and both of my parents actually grew up in Pakistan.
That is the beginning 25 years of my life where I spent and I feel,
which is a pretty young country and it's,
it's just struggled so much to keep its democracy alive and healthy.
And, uh, I, I saw and, uh,
the consequences of not getting the full damn democracy there in Pakistan.
Uh, so that, uh,
then after living 25 year of next 25 years of my life in America,
I really found out the value of democracy as an individual and a,
as a, as a group also. So that like,
I can differentiate now very well between the, those two.
So that's kind of how I've always understood our democracy.
Um, but then Simon,
I listened to your Ireland story with all of this rank choice voting stuff and,
and that's the first moment when I was like, oh,
like maybe maybe our way of doing things is broken.
Like maybe we do need an app.
Okay. And okay. Why, what,
what about it made you switch teams?
Because um,
it made me suddenly aware of the fact that in our system candidates don't
actually need a majority of the votes to win. Right. So you,
you have candidates who then make that calculation where they say,
I only really have to win the votes of people who are in my base.
And if that's, if those, if my base is bigger than everybody else's base,
then like screw everyone else. Yeah.
It seems like in a democracy,
most people should vote for the person who wins,
not just that the person who wins is going to have the biggest base to like a
bigger base than everybody else.
Like it should be that most people are in some way in some preference supporting
the person who comes to power.
Yeah, exactly. And it's funny, like when I heard about rank choice voting,
I was like, oh, like this system is so cool because it,
it's, I feel like it addresses that exact problem. And so I,
I totally got sucked into it and I started looking around and it turns out there
are a bunch of people who think that this could be used here in the u s and not
only that, it already is. And when I asked around, uh,
a number of people pointed to this moment in 2000 with the election when, uh,
Bush loses the popular election,
but he wins because he wins in Florida. Um,
and so people look at the,
the results in Florida and see that a bunch of votes that might have gone to Al
Gore, they go instead to Ralph Nader who then becomes,
you know, sort of notorious as this spoiler,
that that may be ruined the election for Al Gore.
And after 2000 at that point,
you do see some cities that start to adopt rank choice voting at the local
level. And so what I did is,
um, okay, I'm putting my phone on airplane mode.
I grabbed Latif and we kind of did this.
I'm like cross country rank choice voting tour. Um,
and the first place we're gonna start with Hello San Francisco.
Yes. San Francisco is here is San Francisco. Is this Dominic? Yes, it is.
Oh hey Dominic, what's up? Hi. What's up?
So this is Dominic for Casa check. Check. Check. Yeah, he,
he used to do radio. You got the pipes for it, Dominic. Hey,
let me know if you need any ad spots so we can get right to it, you know. Okay,
cool.
But he, uh, now he's a reporter at the San Francisco Chronicle.
I'm a city hall reporter for the Chronicle. Yes.
So the very first rank choice election in San Francisco happened in 2004,
um, but it was actually a ranked choice. Voting became, uh,
I guess the city's method or the city system, if you will. Uh,
back in 2002 where there was a, a ballot initiative that was passed by voters.
Um, uh, that said like, look,
this is going to be the system that we're going to implement going forward.
So the vast majority of local elected offices are chosen with,
with rank choice contest.
So City Council,
the Board of Supervisors, the school board, um, our like assessor recorder
and in one very specific election,
the case in the mayor's race,
the case in the mayor's race.
Okay, great. I can't believe this was just a few months ago.
It seems like a long time ago at this point. Um,
okay, so early 2018, the San Francisco mayor's race kicked off
and when it really kicked into gear,
there were three leading candidates you had.
Hi, I'm board of supervisors President London breed,
London breed. Um, and you had, hello,
I'm Mark Leno, former San Francisco supervisor, Mark Leno.
And you had, hi, I'm Jane Kim, occurrence supervisor Jane Kim.
And these aren't, these are all democrats who the field of candidates is
set now. KPIX five Joe Vasquez. Okay.
So out of the gate, new front runner in the San Francisco mayor's race,
London breed.
This campaign is a winning campaign. She was the more moderate,
more established candidate,
but she's getting one egg of a bounce in the polls and she hit a fairly strong
lead and a lot of wind in her sails.
Two to one leap over her two closest rivals,
the more Glen [inaudible] and Jane Kim and as the campaign made his way to
election day, things were going pretty well. We are winners. It was almost like,
sure there are three names on the ballot,
but at the end of the day it was more like
breed London greed and London breed.
It's a framework. There's a reason falls heading into Tuesday's election,
but then
right before the election something happened that you basically never see in
American politics.
We are proud to stand together to say that we are United in our belief that we
need fundamental change here in the city and county of San Francisco.
In the very last few weeks before election day, the the two underdogs,
Jane, Kim and Mark Leno,
they held a press conference on the steps of City Hall.
Mark and I are opponents as everyone knows.
They stood outside. City Hall literally joined hands and said,
I'm proud to be the first set of candidates to truly take advantage of the rank
choice voting system and encourage our supporters to vote for both of us.
Wait a sec. So what you say is vote for me definitely built from me,
but also vote for this guy who I'm running against. Yeah, exactly.
Vote for me first,
but vote for Jane second or vote for me first and vote for mark second.
So like if one of us were to come in last, like let's say mark comes in last,
if all the people who voted for him ranked Jane as their second choice,
then all of those votes would go to her and vice versa.
That way they actually have a better chance of beating the front runner
London breed. And that made a lot of sense.
They were both quote unquote more progressive candidates and you know,
saw each other. Uh,
at least the rhetoric goes as the person that they'd like to see as mayor if not
themselves. Was that, was that a surprise move to you as you recovering it?
Did you see that common? I didn't see it coming. No, I,
I think that was a surprise to a lot of people.
I almost had to do a double take when I saw these new campaign posters
supporting both Jane Kim and Mark Leno for mayor. After that press conference,
Mark Leno and Jane Kim started appearing in campaign ads together.
I'm Jane Kim and I'm Mark Leno campaigning for one another.
Mark and I are opponents, but Jane and I agree you should pick our next mayor,
not the billionaires. So basically the whole campaign is like,
if you don't vote for me first, then at least vote for me. Second,
let's stand together.
Vote for me and Mark Leno vote for me and Jane Kim.
Alright. KPIX five Joe Vasquez is with the London breed campaign.
We're just moments ago braid address the crowd, Joe. So on election night,
uh, London breed has a pretty commanding lead, uh,
as the polls are coming to a close and basically she's trying to get up to this
marker of 50% of the votes plus one vote. That's a majority.
Um, and if she can get to that, then she wins.
There's no rank choice runoff. There's no vote swapping. Um,
and as the night goes on,
she has not yet declaring victory, but this crowd is celebrating.
She's got like a double digit leap. Like things are looking pretty good.
They are celebrating the person they believe could be the next mayor of San
Francisco.
Holy smokes,
she's beating Mark Leno by 10 percentage points and she's beating Jane Kim by
more than that. So we're getting to midnight.
I'm completely bleary-eyed staring at my laptop,
refreshing the department of elections website every few seconds when 1230 at
night,
it happens in the early returns. London breed had a sizable lead,
but she didn't reach 50%. She came in just shy of 50%.
So the ranked choice voting system kicked in and all of a sudden this entire
racist changed. Okay. So the rankings had been London breed number one,
mark linen, number two, Jane Kim,
who was in third place with now eliminated in that rank choice system.
But when Kim got eliminated, a huge chunk of her voters,
about three out of four went to Leno because Leno was their second choice.
And now by a raise or a thin margin,
Mark Leno is leading the way the Kim Leno strategy had come to fruition.
He's up 0.84% limits of leads.
The mayor's race is still too close to call.
The race would actually drag on for days as more ballots got counted,
tens of thousands of outstanding ballots.
We didn't have a mayor chosen until I think eight days later when [inaudible]
[inaudible]
in a gymnasium packed with screaming supporters outworked the new mayor of San
Francisco. London. Greed. Yes. Omneo mayor
[inaudible],
Mark Leno came up just short. He came within one day
0.1% or a little over 2,500 votes. Oh Man. Um,
so I mean a, okay, it didn't work in that he didn't win,
but you can't say that it was completely ineffective.
And so, so ultimately what,
what did people think of this whole like Mark Leno,
Jane Kim Coming Together?
The people saw the dual endorsement strategy as well as gaming the system as
saying, look,
they are doing this in order to keep London breed from winning.
And that was that was that your paper, right? That was that. Yeah.
Yeah. Our editorial board, uh, said set as much, you know, and I,
and I think that that's not just the ED board. I mean people do feel that way,
that it was this strategy, you know, especially London breed supporters who saw,
who saw a teaming up a piling on and you know, in this, I mean, just to kind of,
just very quickly, just to zoom out all the way,
I think people just find that weird in a country in which politics ends up being
as zero sum game oftentimes in which you are, you know,
relentlessly attacking your opponent, beating them born. Yeah, exactly.
Exactly. But at the same time, that's very much,
um, you know, there might be some people at my own newspaper disagree with me,
but I think that's very much in the spirit of what rank choice voting invites,
coalition building. Now,
Dominic wanted to be clear that in the case of the mayor's race,
this coming together of opponents,
I don't want to make it sound like it was just some kind of Koombaya thing,
you know, because that really, that wasn't the case.
But at the very next stop on our tour, we actually found that case,
the Kumbaya case. Hey Curtis, are you there?
Which also on the line we have let this, hi, how are you doing? Hey, what's up?
We heard about from this Guy Curtis Gilbert,
and I'm a reporter at American public media,
but I used to be a reporter at Minnesota public radio.
So Curtis told us in Minneapolis,
they actually started using rank choice voting in 2009
but it's gotten much more interesting since then. So in um,
2013 was the first time Minneapolis actually had like a competitive mayor's
race. Uh, under rank choice voting
rules are record breaking number of candidates vying to succeed.
Minneapolis mayor r t ride back who's stepping down at the end of this year,
35 candidates signed up to run to replace him. Oh Wow.
Yeah. Curtis Gilbert covers Minneapolis politics. He joins me in studio. Wait,
you're going to be busy shot. You betcha. I mean, there were so many, I mean,
35 candidates is a lot. Unlike the race in San Francisco,
the mayoral race in Minneapolis, people say, aren't you?
The Republican did have more diverse candidates. And I say, sure.
I've done some work in the Republican Party and I also stand fiercely for
marriage equality. Always have, there was a republican and independent,
a bunch of Democrats.
It was a wide open, free for all race. And it was really,
it was really interesting
that despite all that,
they were very, very civil.
Thank you very much. It's nice to see you're not utterly infallible.
I always saw very, very gentle to each other.
Won't be rude with each other. It doesn't benefit us to be rude with each other.
And this is one thing that the advocates of rank choice voting, um,
sort of look at as a positive. You know, voters don't,
voters are turned off by negative campaign and there's a theory that goes that
if you're hoping to get like second and third choice votes,
you'll be much nicer to your opponents so you don't alienate their supporters
and maybe you get a second or third choice vote.
And it did seem like there was an element of that playing out,
um, in, in the race. Uh,
I will talk more about the issues because I think I've run out of time.
Thank you. So at worst there was like some light ribbing.
They said we could finish our sentences if we've run out of time,
but I think that was a run on sentence,
polite stage logistics. Getting out of that chair is a little challenging.
So we may want to pass the microphone around and
thank you. Thank you, Jackie. Plenty of thank you. Yeah, I mean the,
the most remark,
well one of all was the final debate.
Oh God. [inaudible]
I was there and it was in a church, I think it was in downtown Minneapolis.
The camera with the church was, um,
and at the end of the debate, the candidates,
and I think there were eight of them
all kind of put their arms around each other and one of them suggested that they
all sing
[inaudible] yeah. Bye y'all.
[inaudible] after the debate, after the debate.
Oh no,
that's fine. Great. Great.
So it's like, I mean it's almost like a cartoon, right? Like the, the Kumbaya.
It's really funny, right? But it's also, it's, it's also,
I think for a lot of people right now that feels like a relief.
It feels like a relief to hear politicians not biting each other's heads off.
And that's, that's something that comes from rank choice voting.
You find consensus, you find coalition,
you find commonalities instead of differences.
But that also flattens everyone out. If,
if everyone ends up running to the middle and then you just have kind of a,
a,
a bland consensus where no one's seeing bold things and everybody is just kind
of middle. So in a way, when you make this choice,
you're choosing for do this carefully.
Write carefully that I wondered about that because I was thinking maybe don't do
this carefully. Maybe have a country that can be dynamic,
although right now I'm not so sure. So two dynamic. Yeah,
but that is in deep in a deep way. That's what's being asked here.
Like what do we, what do we actually want?
Like do we want a system where you know,
you are lined up behind your alpha dog, who's gonna,
who's gonna argue for all of the things you want and, and,
and maybe you're gonna get him, but maybe you're also gonna lose them all or,
or do you want it, you know, be in a system where, you know, you're,
we're all kind of sort of be grudgingly bought into our second place person who
we can kind of get behind. But like, it definitely wasn't our, you know,
it's not our ideal.
And I think that's a question that's like a soul searching kind of a question.
Like what do you want and what do we want this country to be? Right.
And for that reason I like, I don't know how I feel about it.
It's going to be perfect. I think what's really
interesting is what seems sort of mechanical and um,
technical.
It does affect the tone of your country and of history.
So the world we've got is the function of how we vote.
Now change the system of Foley vote. You might get a very different world.
How different, what different. We're different, which kind of different, scary,
different, good, different, you don't know.
Well,
we might actually know soon because I actually have one more stop on our cross
country ranked choice voting tour
steed may the great state of Maine leave.
We sing super politically diverse, fiercely independent,
like a lot of independent voters.
[inaudible] and in fact,
in in 2016 there was this coalition of Independence and Democrats that managed
to get this ballot initiative that would change all statewide elections to rank
choice voting statewide. Yeah.
And right choice voting was adopted in 2016 according to Maine public radio
reporter Steve Misler, it passed,
it passed. However, with a major flaw,
it's a scam. It undermines the integrity of our election process.
The state Senate, which was under Republican control at the time,
picked up on this constitutional conflict within a conflict within the state
constitution. We're not happy
blatantly opposed to it very unconstitutional.
The Maine Constitution literally says you have to use a plurality vote.
The word plurality is actually written in the constitution as opposed to a
majority. Correct,
and ultimately the main legislature passed a law that delayed implementing rank
choice voting. Right.
Lacy is one more example of where the politicians are extended against the will
of the people and it set off this whole fight where where people rallied against
the state legislature and held another vote in June.
Literally this past June,
people gathered at the State House this morning to get around the delay
[inaudible] through what was built as a people's veto that passed
20 almost the exact same margin,
if not slightly more than when it passed originally in 26 [inaudible].
At some point, the Maine Supreme Court gets involved.
And really the details of this are all kind of a mess.
But what it boils down to is this, in the upcoming elections,
like the midterms that are happening now,
Maine will use ranked choice voting for it's congressional races.
We have three of them this year. We have a first congressional district race,
it'll be used in that contest.
And also in Maine Second Congressional district, which is a swing seat, one of,
you know, a dozen or so nationally,
a k one of the districts that everybody's going to be watching in the midterms.
And on top of that, they're going to use rank choice voting for the Senate,
the US Senate campaign. It will be used in that contest. Do you know,
is this the first time it's going to be used, uh,
for a position in the federal government? Yeah, no other state has ever done it.
Oh Wow. But at the same time, because of their state constitution,
it's not being used in the gubernatorial race.
So does the ballot just like look insane?
Like part of it is like this rank choice voting thing and,
and part of it is, isn't like they're just separate.
So they're separate valves for the federal races.
And then there's a separate one for the statewide one. So the,
I haven't actually seen how many ballots that voters are handed.
So this is really going to happen now. Like, like this week? Yeah. Oh yeah.
Two main claims of rank choice voting are being put to the test
in the very first, in his very first rollout in Maine,
voters in Maine will head to the polls later this month,
whether it can work for a third party or independent candidates choice.
But it's also a test case about whether or not it does what it promises.
He just told another big fib right in front of everybody in me.
You're lying about my Roger's re reduce scorched earth campaigns.
I don't know where you getting this Tiffany box. The general
[inaudible] may go low. He kicked [inaudible] to the Santa's slide.
2129 voted as much as you
[inaudible] they've gone
[inaudible] house in the center.
But also,
I guess I'd,
I just wonder if the people of Maine are going to come out of this election
feeling a little bit more like,
like democracy is working for them.
Wouldn't it be interesting if in Maine somebody who was, you know,
everybody's eighth choice gets elected to Congress.
I bet. We'll see. Yeah.
This radio lab was reported by Latif Nasser,
Simon Adler and Susie Lichtenberg Syrah,
Tracy hunt produced by Simon Adler, Matt kilty,
Sakari as soon as you'd like to bury our story on
p r s T v was produced with support from RTEs drive time. Huge.
Thank you to them and to AP for making that possible. Also,
thanks to Rob Richie at fair vote. Dawn, sorry. Diana LaGermas. Thank you.
Two on a Luhrmann and the rest of the team at the varieties of democracy
institute and Sweden as well as Carolyn Tolbert.
Bobby Agee and Edward Still.
I remember Krulwich and I'm lots of Nasr and thanks for listening.